So the first thing we want to do is we want to go to the event graph, so we click on the
event graph here. If you can't find your event graph just go to window and make sure
your viewpoint is set and then it should reappear for you. But yeah closing and opening
that blueprint should make it reappear for you. And what we'll do is we will select
the box on the top left hand side here. On the details panel, again this details
panel that we spoke about when editing the the box extent. I'm going to scroll down
using my mouse wheel or you can use the bar and we see a series of events here
that we can call. So we're going to go to select on component begin overlap
which is the second event and we're just going to click this big green
plus arrow that looks really inviting to us so let's go ahead and click that.
So we've got on component begin overlap. Now this is an event inside of
Unreal Engine. This will fire some kind of information so it comes out of this
white execution pin so whatever this event fires it will come out of here
and that will be executing a series of blueprints depending on what we decide
to happen. Let's not worry too much about these other outputs for now
you'll get into these as you continue in your blueprint journey. Today we'll
probably only be using the other actor one for context but let's just think
about the execution flow for now and now we've added this begin overlap. Now if
you don't see this if you don't see in brackets box it means that that box
isn't referring to this and when you click on the box you'll be able to see
on begin overlap it says view and you can see that so if you can't see that
now and it doesn't say box in brackets then be sure to just go back to your
box blueprint or your box component sorry and make sure the begin overlap is
there. Now in the aim of good naming conventions let's rename box so I've
just clicked it click the property just to rename it's a single click and
then single click again to rename or we can right-click rename or you can
hit F2 and I'm gonna call this player overlap and as your blueprints get
bigger and the code gets more complex just good naming conventions
will really help you in the long run so we rename this player overlap we
can see this is updated to player overlap we'll compile and save now we need to
figure out the functionality what do we want to happen when the player
overlaps the door well let's think about opening the door so we want to
get this door and we want to rotate it open so you'll see that when I
rotated this door again you don't need to do this but you'll see the
rotation is minus 50 so when I rotate close it it's at zero when I rotate it
open say to 80 degrees it's minus 80 degrees so let's go ahead and do that
let's set the rotation of the door so to get a gameplay functionality based
on a component on this list you can actually just drag and drop it out so
I'm going to get the door and drag and drop which is just left mouse drag
drag and drop and then I'm going to drag off the blue output I'm going to say
set relative so set relative and we want to set relative rotation so
select set relative rotation from the list now I'm going to drag out of the
white execution box and into this execution box and it's good thing to
note here that all blueprint code will always fire from left to right it will
always follow that that sequence so we're getting the door we're sensing the
rotation and the the Z rotation that we just saw when we rotated the door
in our viewpoint was let's call it 80 degrees and let's see what happens
here we can go to minus 90 to make it fully open but let's just see what
happens here so we compile we save we go back into our map let's go to play and
let's run over to our door and see what happens now we're on the opposite
side of the door if you notice there so I'm just going to go from the
correct way first and we open the door set it to 80 degrees now just as a
quick debugging I want to hit escape I'm going to go back to the door and
you'll see in the top right hand side here you'll see BP door which is
selected so make sure that you have your BP door it doesn't need to say
selected because that's just because we have it selected in the map but as
long as it says BP door that's what you're looking for and I'm going to get
my blueprint window I'm just going to drag it down maybe if you're working on
a second screen you could drag it over to your second screen and yet again you
don't have to do this but I just want to show you the flow of logic here so I
want to find find a space on my screen where I can see these two
blueprint nodes and what I'm going to look for is I'm going to look for
something that activates this line and as soon as I walk over to that door
you'll see that line fire and you'll see it set the rotation so I'm just
going to hit play again I'm going to run over to this door picking up my
weapon as I go just in case there's anything through the door that I need
to attack I'm going to go over to my door and you'll see that that blueprint
pin fired on the bottom right hand side there so again I'll just do it quickly
again you'll see that I run over to the door and you see the blueprint pin
fire and that shows that our code is executing so if we just drag it back
up there if ever you run into blueprints that aren't working anything
why is this not working the first thing to do would be to add your debug drag
the window into view so you can see it and it's just a good process for those
from C++ you can actually add breakpoints to your code by hitting f9
so if you ever hit f9 on your keyboard so we hit f9 you can add a
breakpoint to this which will stop the the gameplay going so if I zoom out
and I hit play I hit the door and it will stop at that blueprint point so
it's paused my game it says you've hit this breakpoint and you you may want
to find some functionality that's going on so that's more advanced blueprint in I
think it's worth noting for now because it's just useful to know if
your blueprints aren't working but at least we've got something that sets the
rotation of the door when we hit it to 80 degrees we can either stop when
we hit this breakpoint or hit play so I'll just resume here and so we can't
get through the door at the moment that must be because we've got some kind of
collision we've had that breakpoint again so I can just remove that but we
see our door working we can't go through it yet so maybe we'll make
that door a little bit wider but for now we've got our blueprint code in a
good place I'm just gonna stop playing I'm gonna turn off this breakpoint by
hitting f9 on my keyboard and now we'll figure out how to make the door open a
little bit more cleanly we've set the rotation of the door but how do we
make it lerp open how do we make that door look a little bit better so
let's go ahead and do that now